لذلك هناك واحد في الطريق أخبرني
التعامل مع
كلب أنا لا أعتبر ذلك
إهانة هذا لطيف
الكلب هو
مخلص هو
المؤمن لا يكذب ولا يدافع عن أحد
التطهير العرقي كلب بسبب
السؤال الذي أطرحه على هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين لديهم
تأثرت لديهم الحق في ذلك
من الطبيعي أن تتعرض للضرب من قبل tuie
أكتوبر الأبرياء ولكن أين أنتم
دموع لسكان
غزة لماذا لا تبكي لماذا
لا تغضب عندما يكون هناك
الشباب الرجال النساء
الأبرياء الذين يموتون تحت
التفجيرات أين دموعك في هذا
الموظفين الذين لديهم قلب
يترك للفلسطينيين قلباً
الفحم نلوم القادة
الإسرائيليون لما يفعلونه بالقولون
السياسة
جزء من ال
القصف نريده فقط
السلام والسلام يبدأ لأن كل شيء
ينبغي على القادة الأوروبيين أن يقولوا و
هذا هو سبب حشدنا
المهم ج النار
أوقفوا هذا الجنون، هذا هو مكانه
لعب الأصدقاء في أوروبا لعبت لأنه
أن الدولة الإسرائيلية تفعل ذلك لأنها
ويعرف أنه مدعوم من الدول
الأوروبيون من قبل زعماء أور
من قبل الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية الحرية
لتحرير الشعب الفلسطيني من
جميع الرهائن مشتعلون ويعيشون
فلسطين حرة شكرا
أنتم